I'm Max Keiser this is the Kaiser report
you know we talk a lot on the show many
years about economy and currencies and
what makes a currency usually what makes
a currency is scarcity for example gold
is a currency it's money because it's
scarce that's the primary reason people
use it as money Keynesian economics or
socialism is usually unworkable because
the people who are organizing it think
that well you can just print all the
money you need you need a program print
more money there's socialism for banks
on Wall Street as was pointed out
recently in one of the big presidential
debates you know Bank gets in trouble
will just print more money well what's
the ultimate scarce commodity what is
the ultimate scarce commodity think
about it what is the ultimate scarce
commodity Stacie the most scarce
commodity of all is time and that isn't
a headline here IKEA becomes first
retailer to let customers pay using time
IKEA is now letting customers pay for
goods with their time yes that's right
the more time customers spend traveling
to Ikea the more they can buy because
beginning from this month IKEA Dubai is
running a campaign that will allow
customers to spend their time as a
currency simply by showing IKEA checkout
staff their Google Maps timeline which
proves how much time they spent
traveling to Ikea stores now this is
fascinating on a number of different
levels first of all IKEA is recognizing
that time has value time has value in
traditional financial markets time also
has values and it's expressed in an
interest rate a 2-year bond five-year
bond ten-year bond would yield greater
interest because it is good for a
greater amount of time and time has
value so it's remarkable that we live in
an era in the 21st century the era of
negative interest rates which implies
that not only does time have no value
but the value of time is negative that's
what Wall Street wants you to believe
that's what central banks in Europe
that's what Denmark wants its savers who
put deposits at Saxo Bank to believe
that they can confiscate wealth with a
negative interest rate because according
to SAC so not only does time have no
value but it has less than zero value
here's IKEA
oh you know what time has value we're
gonna pay you for that time in a
discount you make a purchase at our
store the point I think is that going
forward now the ultimate scarce
commodity of time will factor heavily
into all kinds of financial products in
our lives and I'm waiting for someone to
invent the time futures contract
we're imagine if you can trade time on a
futures contract you could travel
backwards and forwards through time
which would be great especially for
Goldman Sachs if they want to go
backwards in time and steal from
customers from 20 years ago they can do
so with a time futures contract we've
kind of had that in a way and that's
what you're seeing here in the US
elections I believe either it's like
some other nation and their diabolical
memes or it's the young people who are
basically witnessing time-travel ie the
Boomers collateralised I they pull
forward the next 4050 years of
consumption and it was there it was the
Millennials in generation Z that they
they they consumed their lives so that's
why there's this awkward moment of when
we're at zero rates interest rates time
no longer has value because 40 years ago
when interest rates were up at 20% there
used to be more value to time now we're
all the way down at 0% and where do we
go from here we're trying to do negative
we're trying to go back in time and and
take back some of that future
consumption that we already spent so
yeah this is an interesting right
lowering interest rates down to zero you
encourage hyper consumption in a hyper
consumption consumption for 20 30 40
years in the future is consumed today
you end up with two things number one
the Millennials and Gen Z inherit a lot
of debt because the only way you can
bring interest rates down to zero is if
you issue a lots of debt and have a
central bank buy that debt Paul Krugman
at the New York Times remember he said
it's only debt that we owe ourselves
he's wrong cuz this debt we owe
generation Z generation Millennials etc
so that's where the circle is squared is
that the future generations are left
with this hyper consumed world of
nothing
the second corollary would be something
like the coronavirus
Toronto virus is the product of hyper
consumption due to 0% interest rates due
to China's attempt to compete with
America on a compressed timeline by
floating their economy that's trillions
of dollars with the debt and having
everyone engage in hyper consumption now
we've got the corona virus that's a
direct result and so we'll now we go
back to the Middle Ages as we've been
saying for years now a return to neo
feudalism is upon us since some parts of
China today they are now revisiting
feudal times they've been stripped of
all the modern eras technological
advances and they're digging in the
ground with hoes trying to find roots
and vegetables to survive IKEA of course
you know cuts down chops down a lot of
forests around the world and turns them
into you know cheap bedding and and
cupboards and stuff like that so in a
way maybe this is also them trying to
realize that we're running out of time
and they themselves want to capitalize
on that nevertheless this program is
only available right now in Dubai it's
called
dubbed buy with your time the idea
behind the new promotion is that
customers usually spend an inordinate
amount of time traveling to Ikea outlets
usually because said outlets reside on
the outskirts of towns in view of this
IKEA has added time currency prices for
every item in its Dubai stores which are
based on the average Dubai salary as
such customers are now able to buy
products using all the time they spent
traveling to Ikea over the years in
addition to the usual derms so I guess
it's it's kind of like airline miles but
you're encouraging I guess they're
having problems with people wanting like
do I really want to drive an hour and a
half you know to Ikea but if you're
being discounted the time well yeah
they're competing with Amazon aren't
they in other words Amazon they don't
have the problem the super stores
located 30 miles away from where you
live they have overnight delivery so
IKEA is saying especially sometimes I
was probably going to branch out into
those areas like furniture that IKEA
does and Amazon doesn't currently do so
well and they'll say look well
up and say you for that distance they
arbitrage between Ikea and Amazon will
be closed because they're gonna pay you
for the distance in time that you spent
getting to the IKEA store but you said
something just there that's kind of
interesting maybe IKEA recognizes that
we're running out of time and I think
that that is something that people are
starting to realize you know remember
the Doomsday Clock and every six months
or year some organization I don't even
know what the organization is they say
here's the Doomsday Clock and we're 10
seconds closer to midnight and up until
recently I think people thought that was
a marketing gimmick but I think now
people are understanding that that is in
fact a documentary of where we are as a
species we may actually be approaching
the end of the species so why not rush
out to a Kia and by Chester drawer for
your six-year-old before the end of time
another person who I think we've already
discussed this that sees that we're
running out of time as Elon Musk and his
electric cars
Tesla now his you know Mad Max sort of
vehicle that is apparently doing very
well and of course his plan B
perhaps he has Bitcoin I believe he does
but his other plan B is to get to Mars
to abandon this planet and try to find
more time there but this electric car
story is also in the news because again
this is you know time is one of the
major ingredients in terms of financial
markets and pricing commodities and
anything equities but it's also
important for what we're gonna listen to
here as electric car sales soar the
industry faces a cobalt crisis first it
was lithium now it's cobalt electric
vehicles need them for batteries but
supply issues will only worsen as demand
rises so there's an increasing demand
for electric cars Elon Musk has you know
helped popularize it we're also running
into the same old conflict that we had
with the combustion engine and oil based
cars in the resource how to get that
resource and again that heads us towards
that doomsday
of more war we have some would argue or
some do suggest that
situation in Bolivia is due to them
having a huge part of the global lithium
supply cobalt could be the same thing
because apparently they're running out
of cobalt and everybody's fighting to
get supplies it's actually hitting
production on some manufacturers will go
in too soon right well capitalism works
if the price signals are clear and they
reflect true supply and demand the
problem with fossil fuels in particular
oil for 50 years is that we haven't had
an accurate price signal given the fact
that the amount of credit and capital
needed to drill in the environmental
consequences of burning the price of a
gallon of oil should be at this time
probably 90 to 100 dollars a gallon to
truly reflect the actual cost of that
gallon of oil in a true free market
capitalist system needless to say when
the price started to get to 20 30 $40 a
gallon you know maybe 20 years ago 25
years ago then we would have already
been on the fast track to developing
alternatives to fossil fuels by now and
we wouldn't have waited to the very last
doomsday second to say oh my god we
didn't allow capitalism to clear these
markets in a efficient way so now we're
going to become prematurely extinct but
I'm gonna upload my subconscious to a
computer somewhere and put it on Elon
Musk's orbiting platform to get to Mars
and hope there's not just another place
where I can't get a date going back to
this story just so you know for electric
cars global production of electric
vehicles is predicted to top 4 million
globally this year in 2020 providing the
coronavirus doesn't go full pandemic and
destroy demand like it has in China
there's a 92 percent collapse in car
purchases it is expected to grow again
providing everything continues as it has
in the past and there is you know that
is always an assumption for many
investors they think Oh times have been
great you know interest rates keep
falling forever for the last 40 years
stock markets keep going up for the last
40 years it's gonna continue like this
for the next 40 years so right now if
things continue in the same trajectory
they're predicting that there will be 12
million
car sold in 2025 right well look up on
the search engine there the concept of
Gaia G a I a this is the idea pretty
much that holistically we live in one
terrarium of inputs and outputs and if
you have an exaggeration of inputs let's
say a global cancer that is the
combustion engine going for too long it
will kill the entire terrarium Gaia is
destroyed but Gaia is not without their
own ability to push back so is the
coronavirus Gaia pushing back against
humans is Bitcoin Gaia pushing back
against fiat money I would posit yes
absolutely it all I think goes back to
the study project of the mid-90s the
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
a massively parallel computing project
that I was participating in in the mid
90s I believe we made contact with
extraterrestrials and I believe they
reverse engineered their way back into
our collective unconscious
that's who invented Bitcoin and that is
now part of the move toward
extinguishing everything except what is
truly sustainable what's not sustainable
is this segment we have to take a break
and when we come back I have no idea
what's happening don't go away
welcome back to the Kaiser report I'm
Max Keiser time now to turn to Willy Wu
he is a partner at the adaptive fund
crafting hyper sheet and a specialist in
on chain analysis of Bitcoin Willy
welcome thank you mix great to see you
we're here in Vegas the uncomplicated
conference a lot of great people like
yourself and others are here and it's
having a good time now on chain analysis
what is that why do you do it what sort
of analysis can you derive from looking
at the chain okay so I like new stuff
Bitcoin being a financial instrument is
very unique we don't see this in Wall
Street it has a ledger we can look onto
that ledger we see capital flows so if
you can divine that data you can get a
read into where the markets going you
are also well known on Twitter and
elsewhere for making some good prescient
calls about the direction of Bitcoin
we'll get into that a second but let's
talk about this on chain analysis now
there was a recent brouhaha over a
company that's been paid 50 million
dollars per year by the US government to
trace coins on the blockchain is that
separate to what you do that's on chain
analysis also but it's more forensics is
like who are these people were the funds
going we tend to track within financial
modeling the G R whole market movements
of capital but actually the forensics
come into it sometimes you want to see
where coins of leaving exchanges are
they going to personal wallets miners
selling were they going
are they going to OTC disks that sort of
thing is predictive provides a
predictive signal to the market but yeah
the whole kyc kind of thing making money
laundering there that's another aspect
of on chain analysis we don't deal with
it so capital flows and as you point out
what the Train analysis you get a unique
look you don't get in other markets and
so you're drilling into capital flows
and you're seeing where this capital is
coming from where it's going and before
this what was your were you into
financial markets I traded the banking
collapse in 2008 2007-2008 but I'm a
tech guy so that's what drew me into
Bitcoin seems
this is a new sort of field
bleeding-edge and I really like bleeding
itch right now cash flow is very
important for example you know Morgan
Stanley I believe came out with that
whole acronym the bricks
you know Brazil Russia India China this
was the cash flow is flowing into these
developing countries and it was a new
trend and it was set in motion a whole
period of investment do you see those
types of macro trends do you see can you
tell us looking at the data that now
we've got more institutional money
coming in because people talk about it
but is it verified is it borne out by
the data that stuff that's a little bit
harder with institutions because they
don't actually tend to use the
blockchain like retail retail your whole
hold the coins in your wallet
institutions they tend to hold it a
custody provider and so some of that is
shielded because the zone gets their
phase where we do custody or ownership
of those coins and they don't actually
move unchain the other just legal
agreements sort of a layer to legal
layer so I think we'll start to lose
some of the signal that we're getting
from this huge from from well currently
got the retail side but the
institutional stuff is still sort of in
the shadows I guess more so right well
there's the whole shadow banking system
and there's they're used to trading in
the shadow so it wouldn't be surprising
that they've expanded the shadow to
include Bitcoin but look so let's get
into this idea then that studying the
capital flows you can kind of make some
good guesses about which way the price
is going right so you've been tweeting
recently that the bull market is back
but this isn't training advice by the
way to anyone you need to do your own
research but this is nevertheless
interesting topic what sort of range do
you see so the Knicks talked well so the
bull market is back so we got down to
3,500 so then you saw this $20,000 blow
off top in 2017 beginning 2018 yeah
there's a massive correction as we've
had at least four times in Bitcoin that
I remember going live through and so
your work suggests that
is correction is over and we're back to
a bull market and so where will we be
where's just gonna go in the next six
nine twelve months okay so a lot of the
stuff gives us directionality you know
you kind of see where the stoppers where
investors are like not so happy moving
coins around new guys aren't coming in
we got very good clues at the bottom you
can see the sort of trend reversal
happening between investors then you
know price sort of reflects that on the
markets you know maybe four weeks six
weeks later but we don't really need
three get the price of which it's going
to trade out we know the directionality
we can do other models of trying to pick
the top right like for example you could
go 30 times 35 times the cumulative
average of the price and that's actually
picked every single top in the 10-year
history of Bitcoin and so right now I
believe that sitting around above
$50,000 but it keeps climbing the longer
runs for so it's time dependent we don't
know the future we don't know how long
this bull market around generally these
things are four year cycles if you
extrapolated the current cycle with the
general four-year cycle which is kind of
like a resonance
what you're getting is these pushes
because of the mining happening and if
you imagine it's like a bathtub and
you're just pushing that water and it
just sloshes every four years that's the
kind of the cycle work that we recycling
within Bitcoin if you make a beast kiss
it's above a hundred thousand I think
one of the more common sense predictions
would be around $135,000 timing
signature and that 35x of average cap so
I'm looking at around the 100 to 250
thousand range depending on how long
this bull market runs right so you
mentioned every four years and then you
mentioned the happening so the protocol
Bitcoin every four years the output the
reward to mining cut in half this is the
way that the protocol works and in this
year are somewhere in May I believe that
reward goes from 12 and a half to six
and a quarter Bitcoin
and this is so talk a little bit about
what this means to the supposed to the
plots the supply is being constrained
right this is this is a significant
because when we do this the the
inflation rate of Bitcoin drops below
the inflation rate of gold and that that
becomes you know gold being the gold
standard of scarcity in which we have
traditionally measured money in not
since the fiat world but we've had
hundreds of years before that and now
we've got this new digital scarcity
which is more perfect which will
continue to be more scarce and yeah I
find this very significant like gold is
not scarce launched a few Rockets mined
the estuary about people think that's
not coming but it is coming right the
the cost of space launch is gonna go a
hundred times cheaper and that opens up
abundant resources so you go from this
Industrial Age scarcity which is not
scarce it's technologically limited but
it's nots Kearse right absolute
mathematical game theoretic scarcity in
less significant and we're in a digital
age when you say the inflationary gold
this refers to the mining output per
year and all the gold mines around the
world which is roughly 2 percent or so
yes that's right ok so there's about a
hundred and sixty thousand tons of gold
above-ground right now
and so that supply is increasing through
mining in the mining you know the other
factor on the gold side of course is
that the cost of mining is goes higher
because the gold that is available is
getting more costly to access in South
Africa for example they're getting down
to the lava you know they're gone down
so deep there's at this concept of Peak
Gold which could become a factor for
gold but to your point it's not absolute
scarcity like Bitcoin is and yeah if
Elon Musk's is gonna put up 66
satellites or thousands of satellites
and the satellites are now out there and
we're gonna start to the cost of putting
that type of equipment into outer space
is dropping then sure we could actually
start mining gold and we won't even mind
go because someone's going to
how to mine gold in the the gold market
will collapse because its pricing there
in India just discovered I believe I'm
just working off top of my head here I
think they just found a 335 hundred ton
deposit in the last week oh really yeah
so there's like a supply shock coming
out of India but anyway to your points
so you have mathematically certain
scarcity and the happening is happening
this year and the four-year waves that
you have observed as a long-term
observer indicate that this thing's not
gonna start topping out to a hundred
thousand hundred twenty thousand let me
ask you this
will we see a transition at some point
for Bitcoin with primarily from a store
value it starts to become a medium of
exchange right one of the issues that we
have in the Bitcoin is that people like
the huddle they like to they don't like
to spend it but at some point if I can
buy a house for one Bitcoin I'm gonna do
it right so it becomes a medium of
exchange as we've done this there you go
but that's early
yeah well the velocity is too high right
and people think we need to get to this
lower volatility before we will use it
we will spend it because you're gonna
spend the money that doesn't go up so I
think that you know there's this you
know if Bitcoin wins and then that
becomes a unit of account then what
we'll see is like you know fiat currency
being the volatile one but like it's
it's a while away the the correct way to
look at but Queen now is a store of
value and needs to get bigger much
bigger you know point it's one sixth of
a trillion dollars you know a Fiat is
what 90 trillion real estate is two
hundred and twenty trillion gold seventy
eight trillion exactly they need to get
above gold before we can even start to
think of payments okay almost 400,000
for pigs to get to the gold level and
you think that this is is certainly
within the realm of possible possible
within I think we're go to wait at least
seven years maybe even ten years before
we can use that as a mainstream unit of
account that we will spin from right so
now when you look at these numbers is
there a price a point where you would
look at it and say oh you know this is a
trend reversal
I'm actual
gotta have to revise my my thinking on
this that this bull market didn't come
in if he got down to some level work
that would kind of change your thinking
what level might that be who like I
think a lot of it has to do with the
sustainability of mining I think that if
the price drop below I am NOT up with
these numbers but like I think down in
the $1,000 range that becomes like we'll
start to test the last strongest miner
that can keep running right on that now
let me ask you this what it does a hash
rate precede price or price precede hash
rate this is kind of a philosophical
question nobody I think they have
multiple opinions on this I'm in a
minority opinion on this but it's -
you're my thought is that miners will
always speculate always taking the
speculation that they will they're gonna
make money in the mining space it
appeals to people who want to make money
they'll always put some hash rate up
there because they they they're gonna
they want to make some money mhm so
you're all gonna see hash rate and then
price afterward yeah okay well you know
first off like if we're just down to a
few - yeah and he's not a fast rate then
it's very cheap for say a nation-state -
to attack it and I think at a certain
price point this thing is not defensible
against a very large opponent but out to
the point of which is first I think is
chicken or the egg I think that the two
things are not that with each other and
you and you can't say one or the other
if price goes up hair straight goes up
hair straight goes down the in price
also goes down it sounds like you're
more like price precedes hash rate which
is fine I'm used to being argued down on
this point but thanks so much for being
on the Kaiser report
thank you mix pleased to be here and
that's gonna do it for this edition of
the Kaiser report with me max Kaiser and
Stacy I think our guest Willie Wu join a
cat just on Twitter it's Kaiser report
until next time bye Oh
you
[Music]